si qu'on va retrouver tout de suite
notre envoyé spécial sur place caroline
de camaret bonjour ce sommet se tient
donc à à versailles je le disais un lieu
historiquement chargé pour parler
défense donc
oui à pour le sommet du sur ce sursaut
donc comme le voudraient emmanuel macron
versailles ça rappelle quand même la
demeure du roi soleil bien sûr mais ça a
été choisi précisons le quand même il ya
des mois quand on préparer la présidence
française de l'union européenne et à un
sommet qui devait être d'ailleurs
consacrer plutôt aux questions de
croissance rappelons aussi que c'est
l'endroit où finalement quinze jours
après son entrée à l'elysée emmanuel
macron a reçu en grande pompe le
président vladimir poutine pour amorcer
d'ailleurs un dialogue qu'il veut
poursuivre aujourd'hui à propos de
l'ukraine et puis c'est aussi le 28 juin
de dons que 1919 il ya 103 ans le traité
de paix le traité de versailles qui
d'ailleurs n'a pas fondé une europe qui
allait mieux puisqu'il était considéré
comme un diktat par les allemands à
replonger l'europe dans la guerre alors
aujourd'hui à versailles et bien il ya
700 journalistes pour couvrir la réunion
des vingt-sept 2000 policiers et
aujourd'hui on parle en effet aussi de
défense et en particulier de cette
europe des 27 qui est censé finalement
mettre le pied sur l'accélérateur sur la
défense pour que l'otan ne restent pas
la structure dominé par les états unis
qu'elle est jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a
bien vu qu'il y avait eu un imbroglio
sur sur la question de la livraison des
armes et en particulier la livraison des
avions polonais de 28 mille 29 de
fabrication russe qui aurait bien été
pour les ukrainiens qui aurait qui
aurait facilité leur maîtrise des airs
et qui a été interdite par washington
alors effectivement les 27 aujourd'hui
recherche leur boussole stratégique
recherche aussi leur capacité de
finalement
2 d'avancé des forces armées communes et
ce d'ici 2023 on pense que on va pouvoir
mettre en place quelque chose qui
ressemblerait à ces forces européennes
communes bref avancer sur ce secteur
d'une défense européenne
qui fait cruellement défaut merci
beaucoup car